I think Rishi will walk a pragmatic line
but I think he will be tough and if not
I'll be there to nudge him along
[Music]
hello and welcome to women of balls
where I Katie will speak today as
Trailblazers my guest today comes from a
tiny village in Cambridgeshire where at
school she took an early interest in
politics joining the youth Parliament
after University she got a job in the
Civil Service and worked on several
campaigns from the Scottish referendum
to counter-terrorism roles in Syria and
Iraq in 2019 my guest alleged as the
conservative MP for Rutland and Melton
and this year she has been selected as
the first female chair of the Foreign
Affairs Select Committee in government
I'm really looking forward now to
shaping the inquiries to reflect the
conversations I've had with MPS getting
there was an all-plane sailing she said
of her time that her Rivals dismissed
her as an inexperienced young woman
nazin is a foreign policy Powerhouse
she's carved out a reputation being
hawkish on China we have seen continued
persecution of the uighur of Tibetans of
Hong Kong and outspoken Afghanistan
evacuation let's be very clear what
we're leaving behind the blood bar my
guest today is Alicia Cairns so this
year thank you very much for joining us
today thanks for having me and on this
podcast we always begin by asking was
yours a happy childhood
um it really was I was incredibly lucky
uh my parents had this kind of fairy
tale Love Story which I actually think
is a little bit unfair because it gave
some unreal expectations
um for love and they met in Germany and
it was my dad's first day in Germany and
my mom's last day in Germany in the 70s
and he flew home with her to England the
next day because they were so in love
that that was it oh my God what were
they doing when they met was it by
chance it was completely by chance so
she was lecturing about Irish politics
um on her year abroad in Germany
um they were both incredibly left-wing
and so people thought that they should
meet these two incredibly
left-wing-minded and interested in Irish
politics people and loved sprang from
there but no they gave us they both had
very tough upbringings and so giving us
everything was all that mattered to them
so we were incredibly lucky and so does
that mean if you had incredibly left
when parents she talked about politics a
lot or you're aware of it um growing up
so there was a lot of politics but not
with a kind of you know political party
hat on it necessarily so they always
wanted to buy International Affairs they
were always watching what's going on
there were a lot of debates about the
Rights and Wrongs but because my dad
grew up in Ireland during the troubles
he had a very strong view that you
should never hate you could intensely
dislike and disagree but he hated the
hatred in politics and I think it's
interesting that I feel that so cutely
in the chamber I really hate the kind of
jeering and laughing and
I didn't come to politics because I hate
the opposition I came because I think
they're fundamentally not approaching
things in the way they should be so
their approach really did shape the way
I do things and you were in the UK's
youth Parliament can you fill listeners
in on what that is yeah so I think it
might have been the first year that the
youth part existed and essentially it
was one of those things where teachers
go we've had this email and we need
people to get involved and Alicia
because you're politically minded you
should do it and all I remember from
I've got awful memory but all I remember
from it is going to a big meeting in
London which was very exciting you know
trained to London
um and all the Cornish kids raised this
massive protest with Signs and Banners
about how they needed Cornish
Independence and that's all I really
remember from my time in the youth
Parliament and was it in Parliament when
you met no it wasn't I don't think it's
yeah it's reached those Heights it was
kind of like the first year started off
see how it goes I don't think we even
met with MPS you know that early on the
process and if you had an interest in
politics from quite a young age did you
identify as a conservative or no not at
all so my parents were very left-wing
and I didn't actually I thought the word
Tori was a term of offense I'd never
heard people call themselves a Tory
um I was very left-wing at you know
School Secondary School
um and then I went to University and my
eyes started to be opened to other views
but I also found the union and the
conservative party at Cambridge Dairy
off-putting because everyone had
incredibly kind of expensive clothes
kept talking about their parents
surnames the land they owned and they
all had this kind of public school
education that gives you this incredible
ability to project your views as if
you're Churchill
um so that put me off and had you gone
to a comprehensive yeah so I went to my
local comp I loved it was the best thing
I believe very strongly if we can't give
good comprehensive education this
country then the government is failing
and so I want every kid to be able to go
to their local comp and then go to the
best university in the country
um but when I then went into the civil
service again I was kind of opening my
eyes and starting to think about why my
politics was what it was and then the
turning point for me was votes of
prisoners and I was working for a
conservative government as a neutral
civil servant wasn't necessarily
thinking I was a conservative and I
suddenly realized I completely agreed
the ministers and I thought all these
kind of left-wing groups coming out
saying you know you must give prisons
the vote was completely wrong you've
harmed our community you can have a say
a game once you've been rehabilitated
but you are being punished you have no
right to have a say in a community you
were happy to hurt
and that for me was the start of a
two-year journey of really exploring and
questioning everything I thought I knew
and what was amazing was I knew my mum
would um so I'd lost my dad by then um I
knew my mum would be receptive to my
conversations but I still took quite a
few friends for dinner to almost say I'm
coming out as a conservative
um and actually locked and said well
actually you know as you've been talking
about things we've realized that your
politics have been changing but I think
that's it's interesting when I got
elected a few people criticized the fact
that I hadn't been born and bred a
conservative but I think it really
matters that I came to my politics
myself and that I had to go through that
journey and and having come from a very
left wing household for me to come out
as a concerns I had to be really sure
that this was something I was doing
um so yeah it was it was a journey would
your mother vote for you she would yes
um and it's you know I actually
convinced her to vote conservative
she'll kill me for having said that on
the podcast
um but I convinced her to vote conserved
a few years ago actually as well every
vote counts exactly that in that seat
less so it was a she lives in a safe
labor majority but yes
one day now you mentioned the time in
the civil service so you go into Civil
Service comms um could you did you
ultimately decide you want to be a
common professional are you thinking
about politics and could you maybe just
give us a taste of the different things
you do so when I graduated it was 2009
so it was the height of the recession
and I think I applied for three jobs
every single day since the summer before
I graduated and I graduated with two
options which is one go and live in Hull
on 30 grand a year get given a car you
know a great opportunity of kind of
Lifestyle standards or in London on 50
pound a week but that was also where my
boyfriend and her husband was
um so of course I thought I'd love and
went for the 50 pound a week in London
and it was the only job I was off in
London and it happened to be in comms in
PR and it was the best thing that could
ever have happened to me
um because AI got the private
um sector experience I then went back to
again before I went to politics but B I
got to work on you know how do you get
people who are in gangs to get out of
gangs how do you get people who have got
HIV but may not realize it to go and get
tested how did you get people sign up to
the organ donor register and that then
moved into kind of more controversial
public consultations
when Stockport hospital was all those
murders taking place and the nurse was
killing people I went and lived in the
hospital my job was to advise the Trust
on how to you know manage a live murder
crisis and I realized that I loved
working for government but I wanted to
be in you know in the room
um so I went to the Civil Service got a
job at Mr Justice loved it and helping
victims recognize how to access services
and that was really great then I went to
the mod where I did the Scottish
referendum and again I got to move into
the kind of a that was quite political
with a you know a small P but also I got
to do some really fun things like you
know this sounds awful so fun but
nuclear leaks big controversials you
know issues in theater big problems and
then I got a phone call from the foreign
office saying look we want you to come
work on Iraq and Syria and they talked
me through the drop and I kind of said I
don't think I've got the experience for
what you're asking and they said you're
an expert in Behavior change that's
exactly what we need and then thank God
I said yes and took the job because I
wasn't going to at first
um because I was having an imposter
moment and it was the best thing I could
have done and I got to do everything
from spend months at peace talks on
Syria in Geneva the UN all the way
through to working on Super sneaky beaky
stuff all the way through to being in
you know military bases in QA Florida
Iraq you name it and I was so fortunate
it was the most amazing amazing job
and so a lot of time away from the UK in
that period yes um yeah and was that
when you're kind of interest in foreign
affairs really developed or no I think
it came from my dad you know my we had a
bus of Lenin at home growing up uh and
my dad and my mum were both super
interested in politics you know my dad
had left school at 11 and you know
worked on building double decker buses
and got a vaulted trade unions and that
kind of politics and then the troubles
came along and he got really kind of
interested in that that then led him to
want to go and explore politics you know
traveling around the USSR places like
that
um my mom you know she didn't plan to
study German and got offered the course
and suddenly was living in Germany for a
year they were we were always discussing
International politics at the table and
I didn't always understand it at that
age but the importance of how the
international effects are domestic in a
way that when I was elected a lot of
people were saying oh you know foreign
policy is for those MPS who've got safe
seats and the rest of us haven't got
time of that luxury of a debate whereas
I don't think anyone now would not
recognize the the foreign policy stick
completely lying and for me the foremost
job of any government is to keep its
people safe but you can't keep your
people safe if you don't have a
steadfast economy and it's also when the
economy suffers at the most vulnerable
are the ones who suffer the most so
those are the two core tangents for me
in terms of why I'm a conservative in
terms of you know fiscal responsibility
and then you know on foreign policy do
we have to do and standing up for our
responsibilities so um when did you
decide you went to Victoria MP because
you went for a seat in 2017. yes so in
2016 I decided that I was going to apply
to set the big process and go and do all
the interviews and all that kind of jazz
and then the exact moment that I decided
to quit the civil service because I
wanted to be clean I didn't want anyone
to ever say that I've been political in
the Civil Service
um and the decision was on the
referendum result so on the day of the
result the referendum people in the
office foreign office knew that I had
voted leave
and yes I knew I was the minority and I
wasn't having big arguments people about
it but they knew that I quietly held my
view but on the day of the outcome and
we all found out what happened there
were at least two director generals who
held meetings of all foreign office
staff and their directorate where they
said the words we know the British
people got it wrong
and the fury I felt I mean there were
people in the corridors crying all over
the place because they felt this was the
end of British you know British foreign
policy and influence but the anger I
felt that they felt it was appropriate
to say The British people got it wrong
that for me was and I think I resigned
within the week
um and then I went and spent a month
volunteering and doing things and on in
Lazarus helping migrants land safely and
and did you have anyone personally say
anything to you having known how they
thought you had voted when the result
came through no I think in all being
diplomats they were just very quiet and
catch themselves about it but you know I
I did Express that I was frustrated that
you know a neutral civil servant felt
acceptable to essentially diminish the
Voting Rights and say of the British
people that that really stuck with me
and so that's when I quit and then I sat
my PAB I think three weeks before
Christmas and the letter landed on
Christmas Eve to tell me whether or not
I got on the candidates list so that was
a pretty stressful do you open it before
Christmas or not and thankfully I had
passed so in 2017 the seat you go for is
a labor stronghold yeah right um so did
you I wonder if if you're going out and
knocking on doors do you begin to just
think that you know you might just pull
off a miracle no I think it was slightly
like a 33 000 majority and whilst you
know I'd like to think I can bring
people with me I'm not deluded uh so no
I was thinking if I had to do something
every day I'd just somehow no but I also
spent a lot of my time most of my time I
spent helping people who I thought we
could get over the line yeah Paul Scully
people like that
um and so actually it was that great
realizing how strong a camaraderie you
get during election
um so I loved it
um then 2019 comes along and tell us
about this obviously uh bringing the
candidacy for the seat that you
currently represent yep so um the
selection was on a Friday and there was
a slight controversy with the selection
the night before so I was in broadland
the night before in Norfolk and I came
second and the candidate who had won had
made some disgusting comments um that
essentially if a woman gets into bed
with a man it can never be rape you know
these sorts of comments
um and had they had been raised at the
selection and yet the members still
voted for him overwhelmingly and we're
happy to accept akander who had these
views and who doubled down on them
um and so my husband and I left that
evening went right this is not for us
this is not the community for us this is
not the association for us and I come
second so it wasn't a problem
um but as I was on my way to Rutland and
Melton I think about four hours before
the selection we're in the car and I
know exactly the roundabout because we
drive past it every single weekend going
home
um I got a phone call from the party
saying turn around and congratulations
the boards met party boards met you are
going to be the MP for broadland
um because you came second because the
first person had to drop out the rules
have now been ended you know
congratulations yeah congratulations
it's a conservative safety and that was
a massive turning point for me because I
had to say I'm really sorry but I can't
do that
and I said I can't do it because it was
the wrong Association for me but it's
the wrong seat for me and having spent
the week in it my husband and I both
agreed a four-hour drive each way would
not work with our then 18 month old son
my husband didn't want to live there it
didn't feel right for us nothing felt
right and the other thing had been in
the summer before so this is November
time in the August before we had gone on
holiday to Rutland to Melton because our
best man's from there and actually my
mum's entire family come from Rutland
way back when
I might have to end the producer for
this podcast today so it's a really
fabulous area
um and my husband has said to me while
we're on holiday this is my dream seat
this is why I would love you to be the
MP and I said it's never going to happen
Alan Duncan isn't going anywhere so on
so on so on so the fact that I've been
given the opportunity to interview for
my dream seat that my family came from
um and essentially I said no and the
response in the party wasn't
um the best they weren't particularly
amused there was a lot of you've said
you won't be in an MP at any cost but
you're not going to win tonight when you
turn up around the mountain you will not
win
um the numbers are against you we might
not even let you in to interview
um but we drove and they let me in and I
won on the first ballot thank goodness
and they are my people and I love my
Association and I love my 187 Villages
and three towns I represent
um but that was a real turning point for
me in terms of going so I'm either going
to be the MP for under Melton or I will
never be an MP
so why did they think you wouldn't win
in Rutland
um
I think they were just I think look they
had a real problem in terms of you know
a seat they've been won by someone who
made revolting comments I was a female
candle I'd come second but I only got
one more vote and the person who came
third and the person who came third you
know was from the seat only one vote
behind me you know it made far more
sense that person do it
um but yes it was that kind of
life-changing moment of okay I'm either
gonna give up my dreams as an MP
um or I'm gonna go and win rotten to
Mountain
um so you must felt quite satisfied
after the result the Elation was
enormous only because it felt like my
people like after I after I did my
interviews I walked out people kind of
putting their thumbs in the air and
saying that they were behind me and they
are my people and it is just when people
say they love their constituencies they
mean it but my son wakes up every
morning and says when can we go home to
Rutland like it is home it's yeah
um now you've had the 2019 intake
there's lots of you it's much uh
yes than the 2017 at least and they were
quite a lonely Bunch
um you founded the 109 WhatsApp group
from that controversy
well but also wasn't there a problem
with the number compared to the number
of MPS so Mark Wallace has taken
responsibility for this and I love Mark
so I'm not throwing him under a bus but
con home put out there were 109 new
concerto MPS but actually there was only
107 of us but then I think once you take
by-elections to look out there are now
at least 109 of us because we had Louis
and Jill join us right so you're
actually ahead of the curve yeah well
obviously we just knew we were going to
have so many more victories to come it
was okay
um it also is when you started that
WhatsApp group it did mean that you
suddenly got a bit more attention didn't
it as you hear talk and everyone was
saying oh these these uh MPS want to be
the voice of their end how did we find
this ridiculous I mean for me it was
just the most ridiculous concept because
I'd come from a world where work was
done on civil on WhatsApp you had all
your groups and you'll spoke to everyone
it made perfect sense to me that you
would put all the new intake into
WhatsApp and we'd all talk to each other
and help each other and it has
particularly the pandemic I don't think
there's a single MP in a new intake that
wasn't say it was our Lifeline you know
how do you deal with this piece of case
work because there's no training to
become an MP you know how did you deal
with this how what kind of Staff
structure do you have but I think the
controversy was that there were
elections as well when we first got
elected and some people saw this as a
this is a caucus first and foremost
um and that we did look out for each
other and there was
um you know people came before us as a
caucus to pitch themselves and I think
as new people and new politicians
finding our way that was really useful
because it meant we learned so much
um but I think there was definitely some
every call I think every intake before
that has done the same thing they've had
a WhatsApp group they talk to each other
they've moved as a group look at Kenny's
you know Kenny's leadership bid most of
that a lot of them were 2017 is
um so it was fascinating how it suddenly
became that me and Theo were Enemy
Number One and you know trying to
control the benches when actually I just
wanted friends to you know get through
this together with
um how did you find vegan Parliament I
mean obviously that was one taste of it
initially yeah
um so first I mean the first four months
were just a whirlwind of just kind of
you know oh my God I don't have a single
member of my staff I don't have a team I
don't know what I'm doing I've got all
these millions of invitations one of
these drop-ins where I'm expect just to
pose with a board I mean what is this
um and you were just trying to find your
way so it was a real Whirlwind and then
that kind of immediate stop with covid
um uh it's really difficult because
the people we joke that MP spend their
lives trying to become MPS then once
they get department they spend every
moment trying to get out of it and get
back home I think a lot of us the new
intake love being home in our
constituencies and we love the
constituency work we do and we're really
proud of it but it's fascinating meeting
MPS around the world and realizing that
no other MP in the world is expected to
do the national legislation and
essentially work in essence like a
social worker you know whether it's
someone's being domestically abused get
them out of their home someone's house
is moldy you need to sort that out and
help them someone's mum has dropped
their kid off with their best friend's
mum for six months and someone needs to
step in and that seems to be you as the
MP through to you know I can't get the
surgery I need no other MPS do that sort
of Jewel rolling and it is a real
challenge
and the thing about being an MP for me
is I don't think anything can prepare
you for it I don't think you can
understand it I love being able to
campaign and fight and change things
whether it's the silent victories no one
ever hears about in your constituency or
whether it's you know the big things you
know changing China policy or changing
the rules around Partners at beds during
giving birth
but
I can't say I enjoy the job and that's
the challenge for me because there is so
much hatred there is so much division
there is so much everything you do being
watched from every single moment you
know even does little things I want to
walk into apartment without a full face
of makeup on and then there's
photographers taking photos of me all
the way through to death threats and
having a panic alarm in every single
room in my house and making sure there's
not a single picture of my children on
the internet
um to protect them
it's not an enjoyable job it is tough
and difficult and abusive but you get to
change things and that is the most
amazing privilege and on that Division I
mean some of it comes internally too
doesn't it um because how can you have
more enemies sometimes on your own side
it feels than you do on the others but
maybe that's because we're more
effective politicians so we're yeah on
each other that's the one
um yeah because I was going to mention
uh before we talk about uh foreign
affairs uh the pork pie plot oh yes
because this links to 2019 intake and
obviously this was around the time where
there are there's deep unhappiness
across the party Boris Johnson and but
he was not he was not out yet but it
felt as though he was in a you know a
vulnerable position yeah and that now of
course he hears out and as of this
weekend is staying at
um
so can you tell us about the pork pie
plot I can so look in my maiden speech I
said that you can hear me speak a lot
about the pork pie and I have delivered
on my promise
um but you hit the nail on the head in
terms of it was a time of deep
unhappiness with the party it was in
January
um it was at the height of kind of party
gate when we were really seeing
everything that happened and I'm not
apologetic for the fact that I met with
a group of colleagues in my office to
discuss whether or not the Prime
Minister should continue in his place
there is no other Authority or group
that has the ability to be able to do
that it wasn't the only meeting there
were other meetings and other offices
but we moved around the difference of
the pork pie plot was that the whips
decided to post remember their staff
outside my office count us all in and we
all saw them as we came in but we
weren't what we're going to do turn
around and not meet
um and then they briefed it to the media
and said there was this great plot to
bring down the Prime Minister
um and it's not representative of the
conversation that took place
um and it's frustrating because the
reason the whips briefed it out was
because they were scared that we were
going to be effective and that we might
bring down the Prime Minister and so
that's why they decided to breathe it
out and to go so hard on us but what I
think is an interesting reflection is
that there were a number of people in
the room but there were only two women
and yet the briefings went out against
the two women in the room despite the
fact that neither of us was chairing the
meeting and the briefings were really
nasty you know one of them that she was
somehow did you and Deanne Davis yeah
yeah so somewhere that her love life was
not acceptable and that I was a bad
mother and when your own party thinks
it's acceptable to brief out to me that
you're a bad mother when it is hard
enough struggling you know managing the
two jobs and the briefing was because I
took my daughter to Ukraine I was there
for a bad mother
so I think the port pipelot was a really
big Learning lesson for a lot of us but
do I regret the fact that we felt that
we as MPS had a responsibility to sit
and meet and discuss the situation no
because that's our duty
um I just wish the whips hadn't chosen
to
I said to try and make me Enemy Number
One and brief out you know it felt I
remember at the time as though they're
basically just trying to name and shame
a few people so as to personally goes
off going anywhere near it
um and so forth which I imagine
particularly for two members of the 2019
intake so you
that is suddenly you're feeling uh
probably more attention media attention
than you would normally receive yeah
look you know I was sat in the airport
waiting to fly to Ukraine the next
morning and the front page of every
single newspaper was Port By plot
um what was quite good is that when I
said to journalists about the reality of
what was going on they quickly reflected
the fact that this wasn't my plot and I
wasn't needing a plot and I think that's
because they knew that I'm not someone
that runs around giving you know
Anonymous conservative MP sets and so
they were quite decent to me but it was
created by the whips and that was their
choice
um but they did aim to scare us off and
look it was an isolating time for me
um it was very difficult but at the same
time I'm not going to regret doing you
know what my duty was and then I presume
it didn't
encourage you to support Borussia no and
also because I want yeah I know how
bizarre that someone who thinks it's
okay to brief out that I'm a bad mum
um but the weird thing was also they
didn't even reach out to me so they
decided that I was too far gone to even
bother reaching out whereas everyone
else in the room got demands to come and
see the Prime Minister and they all had
to go and see him and they all told him
some hard truths that he had to hear
um but no I've always I've always said
to prime minister I will tell you to
your face anything I'm thinking or
worried about always politely but I
think the difficulty with Boris is that
people don't realize that when you have
believed in someone when you have stood
behind them in difficult times and
bearman we'd already had our own
Paterson by this point we'd already had
Afghanistan which matters some of us
greatly we'd already had all sorts of
issues
if you've believed in someone when you
feel they betray you and they're not
looking out for you and they've lied to
you that's enormously difficult and I
think it's very tough that this
narrative at the moment the means you're
about regicidal MPS when actually
there is a responsibility with
leadership and I think all of us have
tried to be quite upfront and open but
that but you know when you feel that
you've been betrayed that's you know
that matters as well and we also have a
duty to represent our constituents and
we're obviously talking just as though
uh there's about to be a third Tory
leader this year uh do you think I mean
on the subject I mean I've read about
registered Olympics
but you know third third leader in its
face to the year does suggest that the
party is developing a taste of it now it
can also be down to also obviously
factors of how people are treated but do
you think the party needs to really try
and discipline itself when it comes to
the new leader and how they approach it
because it can often feel as though
there's obviously lots of tricky
trade-offs in politics but
if you're going to have you know one
faction kicking off about each of them
you're never gonna get anything done so
I think from the inside the opposite is
true and that we we don't want this we
hate the division we hate the Blue on
Blue we hate not pulling together as one
Unity is what we all strive for and it's
because we all believe in a conservative
future and so going through the January
to the June was so painful for us all it
was such a painful period and anyone who
rebels in it is not somebody I would
want to you know associate myself with
and most of us just found it a really
difficult horrible time but the problem
is Boris chose to go
um because there were too many
controversies time after time again
where his ministers could not believe
that what they were being told was
accurate and true and unfortunately for
too many of us that was our experience
of that regime with Liz it wasn't that
MPS didn't pull behind her
um it was the fact that unfortunately a
time of global insecurity when people
are genuinely scared
she chose
to not do what we needed to do which was
people needed to see fiscal
responsibility pragmatism compassion
someone who understood what they were
going through and instead of announcing
30 billion of tax cuts that she promised
us as MPS she has 120 billion she didn't
do an obr
and the whole approach was too arrogant
and that's the problem is that when the
country is scared you have to bring them
with you and you have to bring your MPS
with you and I think I understand that
some of those topics hadn't even been
briefed a cabinet when they were
announced
um unfortunately what happened with Liz
is what none of us wanted you know I
want although I didn't agree with when I
didn't back her I wanted her to succeed
not least because we needed it for our
constituents and our mortgages and
everything else
but her decisions were not ones that we
were going to bring the party or the
country with us particularly this
difficult time so I think we are all so
desperate I think that's why you've seen
such Unity around Rishi it's been people
want to see us move forward as one
and now I want to talk about your role
because you have a new run and you've
spoken earlier in the podcast about your
interest in foreign affairs how that
developed obviously first for your
father but then through some of your
work and you also had a role in the
China research group yeah and and then
uh when Tom Tegan hurt went into
government uh vacancy opened and the
Foreign Affairs select committee and you
decided to go for it what was um at the
time it's obviously very uh competitive
vacancy lots of people are very
interested in it so uh what were the
conversations around it when you decided
to go for it so I I really took my time
to decide I think I was the third person
to clear of the Fall that stood and I
really tried to think about was this the
right thing to do and was I in the right
place you have to offer the right kind
of leadership of the committee and I
almost didn't mainly because I didn't
want naysayers to kind of say oh look
you know
um but I suddenly realized you don't
make decisions based on what the
naysayers might say and so I started
speaking to colleagues and saying you
know this is what I think I can put
forward
I want to completely change how we run
select committee so it's not always
looking backwards but also offering
proactive policy Solutions we don't have
them but also when we do these reports
that take us sometimes six months let's
haul in the ministers a year after when
they supposedly introduced our
recommendations and see they actually
have
um and ultimately I came into politics
because I wanted to break down the
essentially the fact that the state
often doesn't work because the burexy
becomes so big that if it gets that it's
reason to exist is to help people and I
saw that in the Civil Service Time After
Time After Time and in the Civil Service
I was that person who challenged it and
said well that's not actually going to
help people that's not going to make it
easier for people to live their lives or
make their decisions they want so I
thought if I can do that Civil Service
imagine what I could do in politics
and so I wanted to bring that kind of
skill set to the role but also the fact
that I came into politics also because
of the National Security angle feeling
we needed more people focused on that
and so ultimately I thought if I don't
win I have fought for the thing I love
and I have fought for the policies I
want to make a difference on and I'll be
able to contribute to the conversation
and then I was blown away
um by the support across the house
people have been so kind and it was
amazing to get such strong conservative
support as well it meant a lot did you
have any of your older perhapses the
wrong word but you know
younger serving colleague suggested this
wasn't one for 2019 I think my age was
brought up quite a lot indeed yes and I
am the youngest ever chair and I am the
first woman and I thought it was
disappointing
um there were quite a lot of Jabs about
my my sex and the idea that people only
supported me because I might be a woman
um or that I somehow was not
experiencing foreign policy despite
having spent the last decade working in
counterism and countering hostile States
um so yeah so but ultimately I fought a
clean fight and all that mattered to me
was that I took the time to speak to
colleagues and say that this is you know
this is what I want to do this is my
vision I really hope I can bring you on
board and it meant so much that people
were so Keen to support me so I was very
grateful and in your role
um what what are your priorities going
to be and of as you said earlier on the
podcast we have a situation where I
think foreign policy has never felt so
close
um in in terms of you know Ukraine China
a threat so what is it that you want to
do so I think if I could wave a magic
wand and kind of change one thing in our
entire country to be our resilience so
the last 20 years quite rightly we have
focused on the threat from terrorists
who behave like States you know look at
daesh look at al-shabab there's all
these different groups and they've been
attempting to build caliphates and
states and to some extent they achieved
it you know Dash had a taxation system
you know all sorts of different things
um so we were right to do that but what
we didn't do in the last 20 years is
look at hostile States and the challenge
we now face is hostile States who behave
like terrorists and that's going to be
the threat at least between now and
2050. and the big problem with that is
that while we've been looking at hostile
States you can't win or achieve anything
in diplomacy without hope but we haven't
planned to fail and that's the big
problem so now our system is not
resilient and when I mean our system I
mean you know our education system you
know lots has been talked about
Confucius institutes which I've got the
government to agree they could ban
um through to our economic system
through to our information system our
cultural systems WIS across the country
could be being infiltrated you never
know
um all the way through to kind of um the
more mainstream things people expect in
the military we need to build up our
resilience across that entire system but
we also have to look at particularly on
hostile States how we protect ourselves
what we do proactively we also have to
look at how we invest in our
multilaterals and bilaterals because we
haven't and the whole problem is that if
you look at all this outrage about why
is China on the committee for this and
why is Russia able to veto this it's
because we haven't invested in our
multilaterals and the third thing we
haven't done is really worked at how we
prevent atrocities and as a un security
council member we have responsibilities
but also that's how we bring stability
and reduce the threats to us so I think
for me resilience is the big one but
then with those kind of three themes
underneath
and Midway if you're recording this we
have learned that Rishi sunak is
definitely the Prime Minister we have
indeed yeah
um so I wondered when it comes to Rishi
sunax foreign policy priorities uh what
do you want to see because I I think
during the summer campaign he was
accused being weaker on China then
there's trust yeah um and also I think
in the past someone said that you know
um his perhaps because he's coming from
that treasury background when it comes
to help to Ukraine he's also thinking
about the financial situation here and
that could mean a slightly different
approach look I think I think there was
it's slightly unfair some of those
attacks because it's his job as
Chancellor to take into account the
impact on The Treasure of the things we
do
um from my you know experience of
working with him and talking to him over
the summer and when I backed him to be
leader
um he was very considered about foreign
policy but he was also very focused on
what impacts on British people so things
like State hostage taking we're
currently doing an inquiry on that I
know he's got a real interest in it I
don't think we're going to see him back
away from our International
responsibilities I think who he picks as
foreign secretary will be very
interesting because I think I expect
that he'll probably give them a lot of
leeway to shape their own kind of vision
um so I think it'd be really interesting
to see where he goes with that but I
think he will take the right line on
China but he will also recognize that we
cannot be running around screaming about
this our constituents are not ready for
us to go into Another War of some sort
with China in terms of what they've seen
with Ukraine and energy so you know if
we suddenly tell our constituents they
can't get their Halloween costumes their
children off Amazon they're not going to
thank us for it they can't have their
phones because there's child labor in it
or whatever it is so I think Rishi will
walk a pragmatic line but I think he
will be tough and if not I'll be there
to nudge him along
and second last question is what I'm
defense spending which is uh there's
obviously been a big push for an
increase in defense spending it was a
pledge and Liz trust made that one had
quite a lot of support Ben Wallace James
Huffy have suggested they might quit
government if that wasn't in place but
now we have a different prime minister
who never made that pledge I think
partly because it's a tricky financial
situation do you think Richardson needs
to make it or so I do think it's an
important pledge because where we lead
on the world stage people do follow us
um Ben has actually said that he thinks
we should get 2.6 by 2025 I hope we can
do that I am not one of those people
that just says this is the Target and
therefore that's what we have to reach
and for me it's more nuanced so if you
look at the office agreement it's that
second strand of work that's really
exciting you know AI Quantum underwater
you know weapon systems all the new ways
in which we're going to have to fight
Wars and defend ourselves that's what we
need to be investing in if that requires
us to go to three percent then we should
go to three percent but if it requires
us to only go to 2.8 I'm happy as I'm
we're investing in the right
capabilities but if someone could sort
out defense procurement I'd be a hell of
a lot happier than any kind of random
Target okay so you'll wait to see what
you see next I will yeah okay um and
then the final question is one that we
ask everyone which is what is the worst
advice you've ever been given
um so yeah it's a tough one to struggle
with but I think it probably comes back
to what we were talking about earlier
which is you know don't take
um rotten to Melton
um you know that it would be the
greatest mistake of my life to go
forward for interview for it and for
that I have the people of brought under
Milton to thank that's why I'm very
grateful
um thank you very much for coming on
today thanks for having me
[Music]